strange it's time  in 10 days  nothing can prepare you  for the truth  everything you've ever known led you to  this moment  stephen strange the illuminati will see  you now  marvel studios dr strange radio pg-13  seat in premium large format in imax may  6th  the multiverse it's dangerous  i could use an avenger  it's about time you showed up  on may 6th  enter a world  of strange try not to break the  multiverse stephen  oh come on  dr strange in the multiverse of madness  video pg-13 you can see it in premium  large format in imax tickets on sale now  doctor strange i always suspected this  day would come  because you always suspected this day  would come i'm ready  on may 6th  nothing can prepare you  for the mind-bending  descent into madness this is the only  way  doctor strange in the multiverse of  madness ready pg-13 seed in premium  large formats in imax  you